so today's topic we got a video that was
submitted by a viewer so we're gonna
check it out right now what's K
Michelle's trauma men Wow
the center I once said what was the
sinner like of my pain of my life I
didn't have anybody not gonna would no
one close to me died or anything like
that everything that I've gone through
has been because of lack of self-esteem
and men being in the middle mm-hmm
I don't think men are good people wait
you think that now oh man oh I don't
think they're good people why not
the reason for that and I truly believe
that the reason for that is like for men
to do things that they consider small in
the flesh of like cheating mm-hmm you
know that that's gonna destroy your
partner but you do it anyway that's not
a mistake to see girls come up to me I'm
the girl they come up to all day long
crying they tell me the most disgusting
of stories that I couldn't even believe
and a lot of times me and the wrong man
will stunt your growth as a woman first
and foremost you're talking about man
like woman don't cheat and you and you
mix two things you said man and lack of
self-esteem what I hear is lack of
self-esteem if you don't have lack of
self-esteem no man's gonna tune into you
self-esteem that's your business that's
you not him not man that's you maybe you
ain't [ __ ] the common denominator about
all the men that dated you and that
ain't [ __ ] and I gave you that is you
I think she's someone who's been hurt
yes and I think sometimes when people
are hurt often and they fall into these
negative dating patterns they begin to
engage in bad forms of self-preservation
and how she engaged in self-preservation
is that she tells herself that all men
are bad therefore when men do behave
badly she's like oh this is to be
expected it's in their nature and so I
think this is a weird form of
self-sabotage
she engages it just to fend off from
fend off people from seeing who she
really is which is a hurt vulnerable
woman what what can what can somebody do
to change your perception was that
something that you feel you're just
gonna carry the [ __ ] of life every day
I'm gonna see a woman when I come out of
here and she's gonna cry so if every day
you're approached like this how am I
supposed to be like oh it's good meaning
cuz I don't know them I haven't met them
other than my grandfather it's not
because you don't encounter them that
they don't exist the same way it's not
because you live in Atlanta that snow
doesn't exist okay and I'm sure that in
Atlanta there are plenty of good men
there just not in your vicinity or you
are not opening your eyes to them
because subconsciously you're attracting
a certain type of male and you're
showing disinterest into the men that
actually are very kind in our very
generous so you're getting hurt right
you're getting hurt in that process but
it is self-inflicted because you chose
to get with that man youdo you did that
to you before you know I mean like if
you choose say if you choose to apply
for a law firm and law firms got
hundreds of offers and then you don't
get the job well you chose to apply for
that law firm you could have applied at
other places if you choose to play music
and you choose the Beastie Boys well
chances are you're gonna get sabotage
there's a song when I hear I hear a
black or a white person say all black
people are bad cuz they never seen one
all it they may see is on TV that's the
same rhetoric that's the same thing not
a relationship now though yeah I'm in a
relationship he has his ways with him
and I'm very cold I'm very
I'm very like like a brawl up like that
yeah yeah I'm like that remember what I
said earlier because I don't like that
she's putting up a facade but on the
inside she's some type of type of way if
you wanted to the person that she's
intimate with who she's in a
relationship with she's showing that
cold exterior to preserve what's really
happening on the inside with a lot of
pain she's gonna sabotage that
relationship then the man's gonna end up
leaving and it's gonna be like see is
the man no no it's you hmm it's you have
you ever cheated who the guest who
together the girl that was out here
yelling your mening [ __ ] turns out to
perpetuate the exact same behavior but
she's probably gonna say that you didn't
let her finish probably said like yeah I
cheated after he cheated on me I cheated
after I was cheated on a reason thank
you voila if you think that justifies
what you did or making any less worse
you are lying to yourself
and he was justifying a negative
behavior the fact I actually think what
you did is worse because you didn't do
it because you want something else you
did it for petty reasons to get back at
the person Wow why do women do that [ __ ]
why do uh are your PI sees you're not a
Pisces he reprises [ __ ] I'm sorry bro I
my own relationship now though yeah I'm
in a relationship he has his ways with
him but the thing is we've been friends
for like 20 years
okay so I met him I was the girl in high
school that he always wanted so remember
what I told you it's not that she can't
find a good man is that she's been
ignoring them I just understood
that's her name what's her name
k.michelle exactly what you thought I'm
like okay so you've been on that for a
minute huh
[Laughter]
maybe that week I dropped this [ __ ]
purse line on I'm gonna try to be as
empathetic as possible I think you know
do I think that men are bad people
no okay I think what she's really trying
to say in this and doesn't really
eloquent it is that men cause women a
lot of pain and if you want to have that
discussion I'm open to that I think I
think people cause each other pain
I think people cause each other hurt
relationships are places of
vulnerability you are showing intimacy
to somebody that you're not used to
showing intimacy with you're showing
them a side of yourself that you're not
allowed to show to your friends or or to
your family members that's what intimacy
really is between you and the person and
so I can understand why people are
giving her those situations because
you're vulnerable and that's literally
what it means to be vulnerable it's to
be in a state where you're weakened and
prone and potentially open to attack and
so yeah people are having painful
experiences and that is coming a lot
from men but just like preach said women
are out here cheating as well in fact
statistically speaking women are just as
likely as men to cheat women initiate 71
to 90% of all divorces so when you
consider the fact that people are
getting hurt in these relationships it's
happening for men just as often as it's
happening for women okay if you choose
today just know you're gonna get hurt it
is part of the process of growing okay
but if you're not learning from those
experience then you're not going to
continue to make better choices
afterwards just each subsequent partner
and so for the people who keep having
the same type of guys who goes through
the same patterns you haven't learnt
your lesson it's like you eat a brownie
you get a tummy ache the next day you
eat a brownie you get a tummy ache [ __ ]
get a salad brownies aren't it for you
it's all that comes down to your diet is
trash so what do you do when you start
to feel bad your body's giving you
feedback town you know this ain't for me
so what do you have to do you have to
adjust you know I mean like women come
to you all the time with this advice
like hey what is this guys ditchin men
are very transparent they are not
complicated if you want to know what a
man is thinking he will show you by his
actions super artists but the problem is
that women women have these ideas of a
hip happily ever after yes and they want
you to fit that narrative and so they
meet you they put up but they're not
really listening with your actions and
so therefore they're surprised when the
story doesn't end the way they want you
are so busy trying to make him fit your
narrative that you didn't realize that
he had his own narrative written and so
you gotta just read his story it's
obvious what's going on but people
aren't paying attention I mean I've had
times where I literally told a girl I
don't want anything serious she's like
okay cool a week later she's like so
where do you see this going how might I
already told you I don't see this going
anywhere
and she's like okay and then two weeks
later if she's on my door crying and
bawling because she caught feelings and
I was like okay well that's your problem
not mine I literally watches this whole
process everything she says to me but
your actions I'm like listen forget what
my actions and the way you interpreted
it to fit your narrative that's because
your algebra skills are good as [ __ ]
okay so he did this that's X and if X
equals this and that and you put Y in
there why why tell him that it's human
nature
exactly human nature is Z and then that
means this [ __ ] gonna catch feelings
in three days you're like what what bro
I'm always surprising so people go
through these patterns where they get
hurt and then afterwards they come up to
these conclusions that k.michelle came
up to as a form of self-preservation I
always tell people you have far more
control than you give yourself credit
for you do far more control so start to
take that ownership start to become a
better judge of character start to watch
how people move
stop living in your narrative and live
in reality and take people for what they
give you at face value if you do that I
tell you man
you're gonna weed out a lot of useless
men you're gonna weed out a lot of
people were here to waste their time and
you're gonna move on to better and
bigger experiences because of the fact
that you are starting to analyze things
from a logical perspective so that's my
word of advice you have anything you
want to add to this whole thing okay
Michelle you know that kind you think I
slam dunked it and then think I know
you're gonna say Kate that's it for
today's videos let's know what you guys
think in the comments below do you guys
agree or disagree degree do you guys
agree or disagree do you guys degree or
associate's degree with
[Music]